Bismillahirrahmanirrahim.  Masha Allah.
Pce asalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.   May
the peace, mercy, and
blessings of Allah be with you too.
Alhamdulillah, I
didn't think about it at all, but Koh
Dondi said
that he wanted to visit Daru
Tauhid.  Allah is the one who controls
everything.
Thank God, he seemed tired
but still wanted to attend.   Do
you understand?  No, it's okay.  That's why
I feel free.
Alhamdulillah, Allah blessed him with
many trials, meaning many blessings,
by mastering five languages, memorizing
the Quran, memorizing the hadith.  Previously, there was Ahmad Didat,
his junior, but he was a plus and hopefully
his presence in Indonesia will be full of
benefits.
Amen.
Thank you for coming.  We are neighbors in
Putra Jaya.  But you still remember me in
Putrajaya.  Oh yes.  Ah because we are
always together.  But we never talk like
this.  No.  Feel free.  This is
his son's child.  He has one son, three,
eh, two daughters.
Is it right?  Yes.  Three.
S.
Two sisters huh.  And you're the oldest.
Oh, I'm already
married.  Oh, already.  I'm so
sorry everyone.  Yes.
Well, thank you very much.
Give us tausiah.
Excuse me.
Alhamdulillah
wasalatu wasalam ala rasulillah
amadillah
minitan bismillahirrahim
my elders and my brothers and sisters I
welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings.  Peace be upon you, and Allah's mercy and
blessings.   May
the peace, mercy, and
blessings of Allah be with you too.
It's a pleasure and honor for me to be
present in the Dar tahid organization in
Bandung and this is my second visit to
the city of Band but the first visit to
this great organization Dar Tauhid and I
am happy to be here masallah
and the stad has asked me to speak for a
few minutes insshallah I started my talk
by quoting a verse of the glorious Koran
from surah Al Imran surah number three
verse number 110 where Allah says
Muslims are the best of people polled for
mankind Allah is  giving us an honor that
we Muslims are the um the best of people
whenever there is honor it is always
followed up with a responsibility there
is no honor without responsibility so
when Allah is giving us responsibility
and calling us Muslims
as the best
um among all the people don't have
a responsibility the reply is given in
the same verse Allah says
because we enjoy what is good and we
forbid what is wrong and we believe in
Allah
subhanah waala is calling us the um
because we Muslims are supposed to enjoy
what is good and forbid what is
and believe in  Allah.  If we do not enjoy
what is good and if we do not forbid
what is wrong if we don't do if we don't
do is we are not fit to be called as um
we are not fit to be called as Muslims.
It is for every Muslim that we should
deliver the message of Islam to our
non-Muslim friends, our non-Muslim
neighbors and to Islam with the Muslims.
Just a moment.  Okay, because not everyone
understands, yeah sometime.
So like this, it's ok for me to translate
by my opinion.
So we are khairu ummah.
What verse is in Surah Ali Imran?  Kuntum khairu ummah.
We are the best people
created by Allah.  This is a great honor
to be the best community throughout the house of bil
ma'ruf.  As long as we want to invite
people to goodness and prevent people
from evil and believe in
Allah.  So if we don't
invite people to be good and prevent them from doing
evil, then we lose our honor.
So khairu ummah.
More simple.
It is fth on every Muslim that they do
dawa to the nonmuslims and do is to the
Muslims.
Allah Subhanahu Waala says in the
glorious Quran in surah Ta
which is one of the most militant surah
of the Quran surah does not begin with
the beautiful formula
bismillahirrahmanirrahim in the name of
Allah most gracious most merciful
[Music]
it is professor Budi Faisal one of
pembina apa ya leader
ar
school in Australia,
America and other countries.  Mr.  Budi,
please translate help me.
I need your help.  I'm stressed enough.
Okay.  I
Oh.  Allah.
Yes,
I just started to learn English.
Thank God.
Good.  Masha Allah.
Allah says in surah Taubah, as surah
Taubah isah in the Quran which does not
start with the beautiful formula
bismillahirrahmanirrahim.
In the name of Allah, most gracious,
most merciful.
Ee Allah Subhanahu wa taala conveys
in one surah the 9th surah of Repentance
where only in that letter Allah
Subhanahu wa taala does not start
with the expression bismillahirrahmanirrahim
please.
And in surah ta
why does Allah subhanah wa taala do
not start with the beautiful formula
bismillah rahmanahim for example
if you are walking on the streets of
bandung with your wife or with your
mother and if there is a hooligan who
snatches the handbag of your wife and
runs away what will you do?  Okay.
Ee is related again to the letter
at-Taubah which does not begin with
the words bismillahirrahmanirrahim by
mentioning the name of Allah the Most Gracious and
Most Merciful.  For example, he
said that we were walking along a
street in Bandung City with
our wife or mother and he
said there were hooligans.  Hooliganism is the
principle of Bandung City, right?  The principle is
in England.  and then take
eh bag from our wife or mother.  What are
we going to do?
But naturally, you learn after him.  When
you catch up with him, you don't say,
you won't say that
bismillarahmanirahim.  You will get
down to the subject directly.  Hey Mr.
give me back the hand back break your
neck.  Hey Mr.  give me back the hand back
I will break your arm.  You get down to
the subject directly.  Of course we
will not be sweet with people who
take the bag from the hands of
our wife or mother.  Of course we will not
say asalamualaikum,
bismillahirrahmanirrahim.  No.  Of course
we won't do that.  In fact,
we immediately and firmly asked for
the bag back.
So in surah Taubah there is a peace
treaty between the Muslims and the
polytheists of Makkaah.  And this peace
treaty was unilaterally broken by the
polytheists of Makka.
So Allah subhanah waala is giving a
warning to the music that put things
state in four months time otherwise a
declaration of war and when Allah talks
about declaration of war he comes to the
subject directly noispl required
yes yes this is related to the story of pistiti
Hudaibiyah you mean you mean the peace
treaty is the Hudaibiah Hudaibiyah yes is
that right
the Hudaibiah treaty yes
this is related to the story when at
that time the agreement between the Muslims of
Muslimin and the Quraysh of Makkah which was
mentioned earlier peiti ee
peace agreement related to the treaty of
Hudaibiyah.  Well, this will probably be
continued later on what will happen
after this agreement.  Please continue.
And but by the time Allah Subhanahu wa
taala reaches verse number 24 now he's
talking to us Muslims.  Heing us and
Allah says
it be fathersum
or your sonsukum
spouses your wives or husbandsukum
all your relatives.
Yes, in the letter at-Taubah verse 24 Allah
Subhanahu wa taala also says more or
less the meaning is if
your fathers, your children,
your wives, okay continue finish the surah.
You haven't finished the surah.
No, if I say you to understand.
Oh, small.
Okay.
Long long verse
long.
So you translate the first part.
Okay.
O you who believe,
if the law were
your fathers, the law would be
your sons, the
law would be your wives,
and the law would be
your families.  Okay.
And Allah continu what are you
considering?  Are they fathers?  Are
they your sons?  Are they your wives?  Are
they relatives?  What is the
consideration?  Are they brothers?
Allah,
the business
in which you live.  Allah is asking what
are considerations?
Continuation of the same verse in Surah
Attabah verse 24. It is your wealth that
you worry about.   It's
your homes you'll be
worried about.  I can't
translate it in detail, I'm afraid I'll get
the verse wrong.  But the point is Allah
Subhanahu wa taala he
conveyed what your considerations are
related to what was conveyed in
the first
Allah if you love all these things your
fathers your sons your brothers your
wives your relatives the wealth the
business in which you deal the house in
which you live if you love all these
eight things more than Allah more than
his race more than doing jihad in his way
Allah says
Until Allah brings
Allah
people.
If
I read all of the previous ones, it means ee, the continuation is
yes.  Just started from the beginning.  Say,
if my fathers, your children, your
brothers, your spouses, your
family, the wealth you are
working for, the business you are
worried about, the losses, and the place
you like to live in, you
love more than Allah and His Messenger and
rather than fighting in his path, wait
until Allah brings His decision.
Allah does not guide the
wicked.  Surah At-Taubah verse 24.
So Allah is giving us a warning to the
Muslims in sur chapter 9 ver 24 that
means you have to love Allah his messenger
and do jihad in the way of Allah.  Now
the jihad is da'wah.  Convey the message
of Islam to your non-Muslim brothers,
non-Muslim friends.
Yes, here Allah warns
us that all of this is more beloved
than evil in the way of Allah.
And currently, jihad is one of the
best jihads according to him, which is
da'wah by conveying messages
to non-Muslims,
brothers, friends
and to our brothers and
also our
non-Muslim friends.
Non-Muslims.  Thank You.
I'm asking a question.  Suppose your
neighbor when you go to office,
your neighbor abuses your mother,
uses foul language against your mother.
When you come back home and come to know
what will do to him?
If your neighbor comes to
your office
when we come,
yes, when we
come to our office, it turns out that our neighbor is
abusing us, it's
disturbing us, disturbing
our mother.  What should we do?
Yes.
What will you do?  What should we
do if the neighbor bothers
our mother?
Please answer what should we
do?
Huh?
Kick
kick.  Okay.
Okay.
Only kick
only kick.
There are more.  Besides being kicked, what else could you do?
What will you do?
What?
Fight.
Fight fight.
Okay.
What will you do?
Punch.  Punch.
Report to the police and wait for the police
to come.  How long?
Police in Indonesia comes immediately.
If you report something to the police in Indonesia,
can they come immediately?
What will you do?
What will we do?  Is there anything else
we should do or what
we are going to do?
What, sir?
What?  Defending huh?
Defending our mother.
How?
How to?
Because we are going to the office,
right?  Because we because we go to we
go to the feet
without any reason.  Yes  Our neighbors are
bullying us.  Our mother without any reason what
will we do to this neighbor.
Kick kick the kick kill or
kill
kill direct.  Masha Allah.  Someone wants
to punch someone wants to hit someone
wants to kick
and then to kill
kill
kill.  Okay fine.
We Muslims we love our mothers.  Correct.
Yes or no?
Yes.   Do
we love our mother or not?
Yes.
We love we love
all of us love a mother.  Correct.  H
okay now let me ask you one question
that who do you love the most in this
world number one
who do the Muslims love maximum in the
world
who should we love the most in
this world number one who should
we love the most
Allah very good 100 months
we love Allah the most correct
we love Allah most now my question to
you
Allah is asking
in the Quran.  Allah is saying in surah
Mariam chapter number 19 verse number 88
to 92.
Sorry
sur Mariam surah number 19
verse 88
they say Allah most graces has begotten
a son
indeed they have put forth a thing most
monstrous if anyone says that Allah has
begotten a son Allah is saying in the
Koran it is the biggest
Allah
Z88
yes.  They said, "The merciful Allah
has adopted a child."  And 89
then
you really have brought
something very wrong.
Allah says in the Koran that if you
say Allah has begotten a son it is the
biggest abuse you give to Allah.
He repeated it again, Allah
Subhanahu wa Taala said that Allah
has adopted a child.  Indeed, you
have really brought something
very wrong.  That is the translation.
I'm giving interpretation now.
Okay.
So after you finish translating you have
to you have to translate me
not that.
Okay.
The translation I'm giving tafsir.
That Allah is saying that the biggest
abuse you can give to Allah Subhanahu wa
taala is to say that Allah has begotten
a son.
Okay.  Now, his interpretation
is that Allah said, Allah said
that what is the most abusive, sir?
which is an insult, yes, the
greatest insult to Allah is
when you say that Allah
has a son.  If the sky had the sky
would have burst open.  The earth would
have spit under the mountain would have
fallen down to ruin.
If eh
oh the verse
I'm going.  Okay,
translate the interpretation.  Translation of interpretation.
Okay.  Okay.
Thank God I wasn't the one translating.
Happy.
90.
Okay.  90. Right.
Continuation of verse number 90.
Because of that statement, the sky almost
broke apart, the earth split open, and the mountains
collapsed into pieces.  90. Yes.
So here Allah is saying the biggest
abuse you can give to Allah calling him
that Allah has begotten a son.  If anyone
says Allah has got a son, it is the
biggest abuse you are giving to Allah.
So in this case, according to him,
the most insulting thing, perhaps more
precisely the most insulting thing for Allah
Subhanahu wa taala, is when we
say that Allah has a son.
Today in our offices, in our schools, in
the universities, in college our
Christian friends they are saying Allah
has begotten a son.  Do they say it or not?
Yes.
Yes.  What are you doing?
What are you doing?
You say you love Allah more than you
You love Allah maximum.  More than your
mother, more than your brother.  Someone
abuses your mother.  You want to punch
him, you want to kill him, you want to
kick him.
translate
it.  So now in our offices,
in our schools, everywhere
now our
Christian friends are saying that God
has a son.  What should we
do?  Even though we said earlier
that we love Allah to the maximum, the
maximum.  Even more loving
than our own mother, than our
own father, than our brothers.  But
now, when our
Christian friends say that Allah
has a son, what do we do?  You
love Allah more than your mother, more
than your father.  Someone abuses the
mother.  You want to punch him, you want
to kick him.  You want to kill him.
nonlim friend abusing Allah, what are you
doing? Yes, he
said,
doing da'wah.
Yes, he said it again, once again
emphasizing that he said that we love
Allah more than our own mother,
our children, our father. If
our mother was abused, we would be insulted,
we would want to hit her, we would even
want to kill her.  Well, now God
is said to have a son. God is insulted.
What should we do?
Da'wah.  Da'wah.  I'm not telling you to
hit them.  I'm not telling you to punch
them.  I'm not telling you to kick them.
I'm not telling you to kill them.  At
least open your mouth.
Yes
I'm not saying you should
hit them, you should kill
them.  I didn't say that.  But
at least open your voice.  Open
your mouth.  Please
open your mouth.  At least tell them what
you're doing wrong.
[Music]
Yeah, at least open your mouths,
convey something,
convey the message.
It is on every Muslim that he should do
to the non-Muslim.
This is a fardu ain obligation
for all Muslims, every Muslim to
preach.
Allah says in the Koran in sur chapter
number 103 verse number one to th
by the token of time man is verily in
loss inara except those four things what
unless those who have faith
those who have righteous deed exort
people to truth
exort
In the letter Alasr, God willing,
Allah Subhanahu wa Taala has memorized everything Allah Subhanahu wa Taala
says, “illahirrajimina
amanuhati
bilhaq wat for the sake of time for the sake of time,”
in fact all of humanity
is in loss except for
those who have four things.
The criteria are people who believe.
The first.  Second, those who do
pious deeds.  The third, who advise each other
to truth, and the
fourth, who advise each other to
patience.
For any human being to go to Jannah,
many more flow criteria are required.  Number
one, faith, number two, righteous deed.
Number three,
and number four.
If anyone is missing under normal
circumstances, you shall not go to
jannah.  H.
So the requirements for a Muslim to
enter heaven are that they can only enter heaven
if they do these four things.
The first is faith in believing in Allah
subhanahu wa taala.  The second is
to do good deeds, righteous deeds.
Third, da'wah invites truth
or goodness.  And the fourth one is giving each other
advice.  Advise each other
in patience.
You may be a very good Muslim.  You may
be paying five times a day.  You may be
giving zakat.  You may be fasting in the
month of Ramadan.  You may go for Hajj.
But according to surah alarr, if you
don't do daw, you shall not enter
jannah.
Yes, maybe you are a
good Muslim.  You do the five daily prayers,
okay?  But if you don't do
these four things, don't do da'wah, you
might not be able to enter heaven.  Only
da'wah is not sufficient.  All four are
equally important.  Iman,
righteous deed, dwah, and
what is called for patience.  All four are
equally important.
Yes, all four are equal.  Equally
important.  All four are equal.  Faith.
righteous deeds, preaching, inviting each other to advise each other
in the truth and advise each other
to patience.   All
four are equal.  Imam Syafi'i
Rahimullah he said ifar
alone wasal it would have been
sufficient for guidance for the whole of
humanity
alone ifar was alone revealed Imamfi.
Yeah.
May Allah be with him Allah mostly on
him.  He said it would have been
sufficient for that.  Nothing else
required.
Imam Syafi'i rahimahullah said
that if only one letter,
Al-Asr, was revealed
to the world by Allah Subhanahu wa taala, it would be enough for
all of us to receive guidance.
It is mandatory every Muslim should at
least be a part time.
Yes, it is an obligation for
every Muslim to be at least a part-
time preacher
and at
least a part-time preacher.  Allah
says in Surah Imran chapter 3 verse
number
103 that let arise out of you a band of
people inviting people to what is good
enjoining what is good and for what is
wrong these are the people who shall
achieve pelicity here Allah is talking
about full time th how you are full time
doctor full time engineers full time
lawyers full time businessman here Allah
is talking about full time th
I Shaykh surah what?  What surah again?
Sorry.
Surah Imran chapter 3 verse number 104.
104.
Get ready Mr. Ruli.  Hurry up
Ibrahim.   It's
nice that I
can Ibrahim.
Imran Imran chapter 3.
Oh Al Imran.  Al Imran.
Al Imran
verse number
104.
Let's find
this one.  Okay.
Okay.
314 yes.
is 104
104. Okay.
This one
minkum.  Oh okay.  Uman yadunaallah.  I and
let there be among you a group of
people.
And let there be among you
a group of people who call to
virtue, call to what is good,
and forbid what is evil.
They are the lucky ones.
So those who are full time, Allah
promises Jannah.
The best profession is full time preacher.
So for anyone who becomes a full-
time preacher, Allah Subhanahu wa taala has
promised entry to heaven.  And that's just
for a full-time preacher.
We have full time doctors, full time
engineers.  How many time dais we have
who are traveling?  You know how many like us
we have?
Very few.  Like ustaz traveling every how
much we require much more.
Yes, many of us are full-time
doctors, full-time engineers.  But how
many become full-time preachers like
Aagi?  You mean the ustaz who travels all over the
place preaching, right?  like to end my
talk with the verse of the Koran where
Allah says is the best profession.  Allah
says in sur chapter number 41 verse
number 33
who is better in spe than one who invites
to the way of lordous
and thatlimah well the
end of my lecture I
close with surah alfussilat verse 33
auzubillahiminasyaitanirrajim
waman ahsanuam
More or less the meaning, who is
better?  Who has better
words than the one who calls
on Allah, does
righteous deeds and says, "Indeed, I am one of
those who
surrender."
Surah Fusilat verse 33.
Mashaallah.
Hello, SH.  Thank God.  Thank you very
much, SH.  Dear colleagues,
there is no such thing as a coincidence in translation.
That's right.
OK, dear brothers and sisters, eh there
is no coincidence in this world.  Do
such Sheikh.  Yes.  Carry on.
Never thought of that.
I haven't thought about this.  Never
think about this.  Never thought.   It was
n't planned either.
Never plan.  I never planned this one.  Yes.
But it happened today.
But it happened.
It happened today.
A can speak English.
The Sheikh can deliver a sermon here,
yes.  Sheikh can convey the message to all
of us now.
I hear you are very tired and no time to
talk and you say that it's over there.
But Allah wants to
[Music]
not because people because Allah.
Thank you very much.
Oh my God.  So this really
is God's plan.  How Allah
we can together we are
not sleeping not
masyaallah
fully awake
because we were doing the programming of
the stage.
Masyaallah maybe 20 minutes masyaallah
then the plane and then on the phone.
Problem.  Masha Allah.
Masha Allah.  He said he was really
tired.  But I told him,
"Many people are waiting for you."  Love you.
From deep in our hearts, I love you all.
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen.   To
be honest, we are neighbors in
Putrajaya.  We are neighbors in Putrajaya,
many of us just stay together.
Only now can we have a long chat
like this.  Masha Allah.  Maybe next
time.  That's what God willing, in Sunday
I'm going to Per and your motivation
makes my spirit to do da'wah over there
is more powerful.  Thank you very much.
Masha Allah.  So on Sunday I
left for Perd for eight days for
eight days stay over there and the many
programs
and now my spirit is more powerful than
before.  Thank you very much.
Hey, do you understand?  Yes, I stand under
you.  It's okay yeah.
Can you ask some questions?
Thank you very much.  Oh yes, at the same time,
he was introduced to the students, eh Mr.
Budi Faisal, professor candidate
God willing, Professor in ITV as soon as
possible.
If I leave later and perhaps will
not be in Indonesia for some time due to
preaching duties abroad, then Abudi and
Adeda will be the ones responsible for Darulut
Tahid.  He is the candidate to be
responsible for Darut Tauhid.  Yes.
Yes.  He can talk in English better than
me.
Masha Allah.  And his experience is
deeper and more powerful.
Thank you, Mr.  Budai.  Hey, Budi.
If I'm going to another country, you can
take responsibility for this pesantren.  Yes.
Eh, so you've heard it yourself, right?
Later, demand to be able to give lectures on
Friday nights or Fridays.
He wanted one question from a
man, one from a woman.
Okay.  Any order
for lady, Eddie for brother.  Yes,
only one from the brothers, one from the
sisters.  You can just be
nice.
One yes, one.  Then one brother,
one brother, one brother.  Any
questions from sisters?
Ah, the one above is difficult.  It's difficult
to throw the microphone.  Okay, the
first one, you can stand up and maybe
tell me your name and ask
your question straight away.
Yes, let me
introduce myself, my name is Yusuf Iskandar.
I am from the Indonesian University of Education
.  Ee I want to ask in the
Koran in the Koran Allah promises
his people heaven.  Well, in heaven
we cannot feel pain
and there is no evil.
My question is, will we ever experience
the pleasure of health and knowledge of
evil without the pain and evil
?  And will we live
like statues or feel bored if we
live without challenges or obstacles?
Okay.
Translate is very important you know.
Yes.
About life in Jannah.  In heaven.
without
without challenge
his name is Iskandar he is a student in
the university of education education
university and he said as we know that
in the quran Allah subhanahu wa taala
says in the quran that in jannah in the
heavens we will feel happy always happy
and we will feel no pain
at all no pain at all
according to him if there is if always
we cannot feel any pain at all then
there is no challenge it is like a robot
what do you think about that
very good question
but always happy boring
so if you read the  had of a belovedam
we are always happy but there is also a
higher level of happiness
and the highest level of happiness and the highest level of happiness in jannah is
seeing the waj of Allah seeing the face
of Allah so always happy
but the highest level is so you will be
craving when will I see the face of
Allah masallah always happy but this is more happy minimum is happy but
something like more happy so you will
wait to see the waj of Allah so that is
what every person in Jannah would want
to see the face of Allah which you won't
see always says he will Allah
will appear on Friday so various had so
we long  to see the face of Allah but
there is no challenge according to him
there is no challenge challenge
oh desire oh ok
in yes
desire
so he answered it in a hadith
that he conveyed that there is a
higher level than just happiness
yes yes
there is a higher level which is
better which is greater higher.
from the happiness we have felt
in this world.  As far as we are concerned, there are things in the world that are
much higher than that.  And
that is being in heaven by
seeing the face of Allah Subhanahu wa taala.
That is the highest level of happiness
.  Okay.
Last question from sisters.  From
sisters.
Sister.  Which one?
Any sister?  Yes.
Please go ahead.  Oh, that.  Okay.  The committee can
help with the mic
.  Yes.
Oh, yes.  Please.
Peace be upon you, Doctor.
Peace be upon you.
It's such an honor to finally meet you.
I've watched you since I was 5 years old
to 10 years old.
And there's one question that always
takes in my mind whenever I see you in a
poster or video.  How do you maintain
yourself in this beautiful religion
when you also read other holy books like
Bible, Veda, Tripitaka, Bhagavat Gita
and etc?  That's all.  Thank you.
What's the question?  What do you do
how do you maintain staying at this
religion with faith when you also read
other books other holy books like holy
bible
and many more.
Okejah translate ee may please
directly translate the question into
Indonesian.
Em so my question is ee how is Dr.
Zakir Naik is staying, or is he
still holding on to his faith in
Islam, whether he likes it or not,
while reading other religious books
.  Sisters ask the question
that how I remain in Iman after reading
besides Koran, Bible, Old Testament, New
Testament, Bhagavat Gita, Ramayan, Veda.
How do I remain in faith?
I was a Muslim
because my father was a Muslim.
Initially till the age of 19, I was a
Muslim because my father was a Muslim just
following blindly like most of then I
met Sheikh Ahmad Didad.  He inspired me
and I started doing dawa.  Then I started
reading other scriptures.  When I read
other scriptures now I am a Muslim by
choice because I've read the Bible, I read the
Veda, I read the Ramayan, I read the Mahabharat.
Now after comparing I am no Muslim by
choice.
Yes, I am a Muslim born
as a Muslim.  My family is
Muslim.
But then I was inspired by
Sheikh Ahmad Didat so I then
studied comparative religion.  I
read the Bible, I read the Vedas, I read
various kinds of holy books from
other religions or
other beliefs.  Because
I compare various kinds of
books.  Now I am
not a Muslim by descent.  I
am a Muslim because
I chose Islam, not because of my descent,
with
what?  With full awareness.
Something like that.
Sister asking me how do I maintain my
faith?  Not maintain myan.  I have gone
very high now.  And I challenge anyone to
show me a better religion Islam I will
convert.  I am convinced with Islam with
logic and reason I tell anyone show me a
better book than the Koran.  I will
convert others cannot say because they do
n't have comparative religion.  I tell
you, show me a book better than the
Koran.  Show me a religion better than
Islam.  I'm ready to accept Islam.  I'm
ready to change my religion.
Uh, the sister asked me,
"How do I keep my faith?"
I God willing, I'm not guarding now,
I God willing I am in
very high, very strong faith.
Whoever can show me a
better book than the Quran,
whoever can show
me another religion that is better than
Islam, I am willing to convert to that religion.
But I am absolutely sure that the
Qur'an is the best.  Islam
is the best religion.
Allah is the Greatest.
Masha Allah.  Thank God.  Now it's my time
to ask you something.
What is your daily routine?
Normal routine or yesterday's routine?
No, normal routine.  Because
because I know your knowledge increases
day by day.  What are you doing?  You
understand what are you doing, right?
I try to ask because I need to make them
understand.  Please tell me your
activity, daily activity.  Let me
translate first.  Yes,
my teacher asked him to the
doctor, how is his
daily life in this day to day life?
How can this happen in everyday life
?  The longer it
gets the better, the longer it gets stronger
.  How is his daily life?
That's right.
As a medical doctor, I know that a human
being should sleep for seven to nine
hours a day on average.  You cannot if you
sleep less than seven hours, you cannot
function normally.
Okay.  As a doctor, yes, a
medical doctor, he knows that for
anyone, it is
best to sleep between 7 and 9
hours a day.  If it is less than 7 hours,
our body usually does not function
well.
Yes.
If you sleep less than seven hours a
day, you cannot function normally.  There
is only one in 200 people who can sleep
six and a half hours and six hours and
can function normally.
out of 200%
half per eh
if we sleep less than 7 hours
per day then our body will not
function normally.  So in
this world there is only how per again
half per
six hours a day
only one in 200 can function normally
if we sleep 6 hours six hours is
that six hours six move
okay 6 hours a day then there is only one
in 200 people only one in 200
people can function
normally.
If you sleep less than six hours up to
five hours very few less than five hours
one in a million who can function
normally
function normally without having health
problems if you sleep less than five
hours.  He's one in a million.
If
we sleep less than 5 hours a day then
maybe only one in 1 million
people will.  one in 1 million people whose
body can function normally.
You can only survive with the help of
Allah if you sleep than other days.
Yes, if we sleep less than 5 hours
a day, then we will be able to survive and
live normally only with
the help of Allah Subhanahu wa taala.
Allah's help.  I on average every day I
sleep for about three and a half hours
on average.
May Allah Subhanahu wa Taala
help.  In my daily life, I
only sleep about 3.5 hours a day.
Some three hours, three and a half
hours, sometimes four hours.  On an
average 3 and a half hours.
Sometimes 3 hours, sometimes 3
and a half hours, sometimes 4 hours.  But
on average I sleep 3.5 hours a day
with God's help.  Yesterday last
night I gave a talk continuously for
three four hours then I was with my
staff looking at the stage.  I sleep today
only for 20 minutes before breaking for 20
minutes today.
Last night I spoke non-stop for 3
to 4 hours then continued
with discussions with my staff,
watching the stage and so on.  I was I
was trying to avoid coming here but
because of the love of us had to come
here.
So I continued earlier
so that I only slept for 20 minutes
before breakfast.  At first I
was trying not to come here but
then I ended up coming here like that
.
After seeing you yet I'm functioning
normally.  God help.  After seeing you yet
I'm giving a talk handling question
answer session.  You have to be at the
best level to handle questions.
Masha Allah.  So after seeing
all of you, with God's help, I
can function normally, very normally, you know
.
Regarding my daily routine, I start my I do
n't know where to start because you
know I sleep twice a day on average both
put together.  I would say that okay in
the night I sleep for approximately half
an hour and I get up for tahajud.
Tahajjud is the most important sunnah
after far.
A it's not further than every Muslim but
for a it's very important it's your
connection with Allah subhanah waala so
I on average when I am at home I spend
about two hours every night in tahajud
I start my day I sleep for half an hour
then get up for tahajud
I spend about two hours on average when
when I'm at home not traveling at home.
Masha Allah.
Every night I usually only sleep for
half an hour first.
I slept for half an hour.  Then I wake up to
tahajjud for approximately 2 hours every
day.  And for a preacher, tahajjud
is very, very important for
a preacher to have a
strong connection with Allah Subhanahu wa taala.
Every day 2 hours for tahajud,
at night sleep for half an hour first.  Any
problem you have, ask Allah in tahajud.
In your sujud Allah will give you the
scholars say you have not tried
everything until you ask Allah in
taajjud in your sujud Allah says one
hour is there any of my servants who want something I will give it to you tajud is the best time for connection with
Allah  Yes,
in the Qur'an. In the hadith, whoever
needs help,
protection, Allah will grant it
in tahajud, in our prostration.  It's
mandatory for every Muslim, at least
the men that they should offer Salah in
Jamaat in the Mosk.  This is neglected by
many Muslims.  At least for the gents,
it's mandatory every Muslim should
offer Salah in Jamaat in the Moscow.
He believes that it
is
obligatory for Muslim men to
pray in congregation at the mosque.  And this is what
many
Muslim men forget.  So he
believes that it is obligatory for
Muslim men to always pray
fardhu prayers in congregation at the mosque.  Our beloved
prophet said, "First thing Allah will
ask you in kiamah among all your
actions is about your wrong."  Rasulullah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam e said
that the first thing that
Allah subhanahu wa taala will ask about on the Day of
Resurrection is his prayer.  It is
our prayer.  where I stay in putra jaya even
the house we have a musla
we call in mal i say masjid in the same
building very close yet if you do wudu
if i the moment i hear the adhan i go i
pray my sunnah all my sunnah for come
back average it takes me 40 minutes 40
minutes for one salah average sometime
35 some 45 average every salah
okay in putra Jaya where i live
close to Sheikh He said, there is
a musla there called
surau.  Every time I pray, starting from
ablution, I come to tahiyatul mosque,
maybe qobliah.  On
average,
I spend
40 to 45 minutes in one prayer.
So multiply by 5 comes to 200 minutes
plus my ta about two two hours then
prayer very important four rakat
add that about 20 minutes all put together
on average every day
I pray for about five to f and a half
average
5 to 5 and a half hours so if
you combine it 40 minutes to 45 minutes
per one prayer multiplied by 5 40 * 5 200
minutes plus tahajud ee 2 hours yes
120 minutes.  Plus there is also the Duha prayer.
According to him, the duha prayer is very important, namely
four rak'ahs.  Duha prayer four rakaat.   The two
fards are two.  So
in all my activities the maximum time I
spend for any activity in my full life
in my day average is
wrong.
Wrong.
This means that in my daily life, every
day, the thing
I spend most of my time doing
is praying.
And on an average of course
my main purpose is dawa but dawa is of
various when I do dawa there is something
like direct dawa something like indirect
now I'm doing direct dawa correct islah
but like indirect dawa last night I was
doing indirect dawa looking at the stage
okay what is the lighting so that
tomorrow when people see on the
satellite 100 million people watching
that's called administration indirect
dawa that because I'm taking care of the
date of the stage today tomorrow million
people watching on the satellite peach
TV they will get hidayah so that is
indirect dawa so I spend on average
about 12 hours for my dawa in indirect
dawah put together everything
12 hours a day
direct and indirect so in
dawah eh he categorizes there is
direct dawa like now direct
so direct there is indirect dawa
like last night he said I
have to check the stage check ee various
things sound system because this will be
broadcast by Peace TV
ee millions of people can see.  Well,
we can also call that da'wah, but
indirect da'wah.  If I combine
direct
and indirect preaching, the
average is 12 hours a day.  12 hours a
day, is that right?  Yes, 12 hours a day
I do da'wah.
One of the main activities of mine in my
dwa is Karat Salam Peach TV.  We have got
four satellite channels.  Peach TV
English which has 100 million viewers.
Peach TV Urdu has 80 million viewers.
Then Peach TV Bangla 50 million viewers
and Peach TV Chinese Mandarin 20 million
viewers.  All put together 200 to 250
million people watching on the
satellite.
Masyaallah, please help me if I forget.  Well, my
preaching was covered by
Peace TV.  PH TV has four channels, four
languages ​​English.
English is 100 million.
Urdu 80 million.
Urdu 100 million earlier, 100 million
listeners.  Then Urdu 80 million.
Eh, then and then after is bang.
Bangla million.
Bangla 50 million people are listening.
Chinese Mandarin 20 million.
And Chinese e Chinese Mandarin
how many?
20 million.
20 million listeners.  24 by 7 When I
am sleeping
Oh, my God.  Yes.  Yes.  If
after listening to it earlier, we have 250
million people who always listen to the
four Setelra TV channels.  This means that
even if I sleep, this will
continue, this da'wah will continue
and I am very enthusiastic to continue
pursuing
blessings.
Sat.
Sat.  Sat.
Reward.  Reward.  Is that ajr aj blessing?
Yes,
yes,
spend a half hours for one direct dwa
indirect dwa administration we have got
school many activities total 12 hours
and I am also a part time businessman.
Hmm.
Apart from the preaching and indirect
preaching that I do for 12 hours
a day, I am also a part-time
businessman.
I spend every month about two days for
business.  on a half
for
ya.  So in 1 month I spend
2 days on business days like ustaz we
should be like that not like that.
As the teacher said, we
have to have our hands on top, not on the
bottom.
So we have about 10 businesses 10
businesses.  I spend only half an hour a
day managing all this only half an hour
because I'm a full time die and a part
time businessman.  yes half an hour a day
one day half an hour average average.
Okay.  So on average I spend
only 1 and a half hours a day and that
too only 2 days in 1 month.  So I
haven't said that I am, God willing, a
full-time preacher and part-time businessman.
And in business make Allah your business
partner.
Now.  And the best thing in business
is to make Allah Subhanahu wa
taala our business partner.  When my
son started doing business two or three
years back, I told him make Allah your
business partner.  And when you make
Allah a business partner, you can't make
him a small partner.  You can't make him
a small partner.  You have to make him a
major partner.  So I told my son, when
you make Allah your partner, minimum
give 51% of your profit in charity to
Allah Subhanahu wa taala.  Minimum.
Minimum.  If we make Allah
our business partner, then we
need to make this business partner
something very noble.  We must really
honor it.  Therefore, in doing business
with Allah Subhanahu wa taala, I
give a minimum of 51% of the profits
to Allah Subhanahu wa taala.  It's not
fah.  F is 2% of zakat.
This is not mandatory.  Of your nisab
levelis.  This is my suggestion.  Afzal.
It's not f and
I am a veteran I am an old timer.  I give
more but for my son is new.  So minimum
51%
he
was with me awake.
I'm training him now.
God willing.
I said, what is this, father?
My son is still a beginner in
business.  So that's 51% for my child.
If I were more senior I would have to be
more than 51%.
In the Quran in surah chapter 2 verse
number 261
if you give one conqar alqarahqarah
chapter two verse number 261
if you give one grain in the way of
Allah will give you seven years seven but
every year will have 100 grains
that means you put one grain in the way
of Allah will give you 700 grains 700
times profit in English terminology
In surah Albaqarah surah 2 verse
261 Allah  Subhanahu wa taala said,
more or less, the meaning of the parable of the living
issued by Allah for
those who spend their wealth in
the way of Allah is like an ee with a
seed that grows seven
grains in each of 100 seeds.
Allah multiplies the rewards for
whom He wills.  And Allah is all-Encompassing and
All-Knowing.  No
interpretation interpretation.  One grain you give, Allah
gives you 700 grains.
His interpretation is that if we
give just one seed, it means that Allah will
reward us with 700 seeds.
700 times profit.
700 profit.
In business terminology 70,000%
profit.  Well, in business terminology,
in business terms, it means that if
we do what we did earlier, AK will
get
70% of the profit in the
business.  If we did it
normally when you do business, how much
profit do you get?  10% 20% 30% 40% 50% how
much
here Allah is saying 70,000%
profit.
Oh 70,000 sorry
70,000 I you made less
yes I made less fai in Allah.
translate
it.  Earlier I corrected 70,000
is
70,000%
profit 70,000% profit.  Which
business do you get so much from?
Yes, usually when we do
business we get a profit of 10%,
20%, 30%, 40, 50%.  But with Allah
Subhanahu wa taala with the previous verse
Albaqarah 261 we will get
70,000%
profit.  request you start giving charity
start with besides your further zakat
start with 10% Allah will increase your
business Allah will increase your salary
then you give 15% then give 20% give 30%
see how Allah in your balance with you
is more.
The more percentage you give to Allah
the money remaining with you increases.
Your percentage decreases but amount
increases.  Very easy.  Do business with
Allah.  Very easy.
Masha Allah.  Masha Allah.  Yes, he
suggested that apart from the mandatory 2.5%, let's
start practicing increasing from 2.5% 5%
10% 2%.  He said that Allah will definitely
make something bigger,
bigger, bigger.  The best
business is doing business with Allah
Subhanahu wa taala.
This wasn't short about what I did and I
have to thank all of you for giving us
an opportunity to come here and may
Allah all of you and insyaallah may
Allah raise all of us together in
Jannah.
Masha Allah.  Amen.
That's my daily life.  I close it
like here.  May Allah Subhanahu
wa taala reward us with the
Farga of Paradise and bring us together in
Paradise in the future.  God willing.
Thank you, Sheikh.
Your words are very powerful.  Looks like
punch me.
Punching.
I'm a businessman but still a half of the
time.
Okay.  After I heard a lot from your daily
routine, God willing, it
looks like Allah gave me a
warning to change my style in my life.
Insyaallah I wan to follow
your lifestyle insyaallah.
Thank you very much Sheikh Jazakumullah.
Thank you, men, you everybody.  We love
you all.
Thank You.  I really know that
when he came he was very tired
.  He didn't sleep last night and
when he was spoken to.
But if Allah wills His law,
you will and He will love
you.  To all the Koh K dondi congregation
where?  Where is Kohon?  Where are you?
Oh,
hauma
ha,
sit down for a moment,
doni tan, yes, you doni, this is a servant of
Allah, I am also one of those who
see a lot of I so many on his YouTube
because it gives me more enlightenment about
how.
Thank you.  I heard from
my secretary that Doni contacted me and said he
wanted to visit.  I believe this is
God's plan.  Thank you
jazakallah khair.  May all the rewards
also flow to Koh Dondi.  We are
praying for all the
rewards.  No reward.  It's ok.  It's ok.
Yes.  Reward.  Reward, yes.  Teach
me.  Azer ajr yes and also he received
this yes because by him Allah created this
masyaallah that's it, okay, thank you,
maybe I'll say something
before leaving this mortal event
.
Masha Allah.
Okay, permission Ayum.  Masyaallah, I am
very happy to be able to meet figures like
Dr.  Zakir Naik and Sheikh Fariq Naik went to
Darut Tauhid to meet with AGIM
directly.  I am very happy
because this is good for
all of us and what has been conveyed
by Dr.  Zeker ascended to us all
today, of course, it is very, very
beneficial for us.  Amen.
God willing.  Well, with your permission, I would like to
ask you to invite
all our brothers and sisters here to
do good deeds.  It's permissible.
Well, for the event we brought Dr.  Zaki's
trip to Indonesia required
quite a large amount of money.  So, I would like to
invite all of our brothers and sisters
here to donate.  Well, yes, you can
transfer it to Bank Muamalat with the
account number sacap-sacap kopek-kopek, that's what it's called
in Hokkien language.  The
Indonesian language is 30 30900900
in the name of the Indonesian Mualaf Guard Event.
Whatever you, sir, madam, donate or
provide for the event of Dr.  Zaki's rise,
God willing, will bring goodness
back to all of us.  Dr.  Zakir Naik
came to Indonesia to give a lecture
using only a venue but it was broadcast
live by Peace TV which was watched by
hundreds of millions of people.  When someone
seeks guidance, whether in Indonesia
or in another part of the world, we will
all also receive goodness,
God willing.  Just like that.  And may Allah grant us good
fortune and guidance.  Peace be upon you and Allah be upon you
.
Peace be upon you.
So this is not for him,
but this is for the SW sound system and
so on.  If he is as
Ongkos himself told him and doesn't
expect anything.  Thank You.
Subhanakallahum wabihamdik asadu
ilahailla anta astagfiruka.
Alamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.